we go live to fox's trey link ingst
who's on the ground in kiev trey what
can you tell us as of this hour
laura good evening last hour there were
two large explosions here in the capital
of kiev we're getting some new
information about what they might have
been the ukrainian interior ministry
advisor anton garascho shared a video
and claims that ukrainian air defense
shot down a russian aircraft i want to
make sure we're very clear with the
attribution here this is coming from an
advisor to the interior minister and is
now being widely reported in local media
this advisor to the minister who has
in the past during this escalation
discussed a lot of
movements in terms of the ukrainian
military someone with knowledge of the
situation again is claiming that
ukrainian air defense has shot down a
russian aircraft we don't know what kind
of aircraft and we have not
independently confirmed this report but
it would be a significant
move here by the ukrainians and it would
also highlight the fact that ukraine
still has air defense in play the
russians have talked about how they in
the initial hours of their invasion into
ukraine took out all of the ukrainian
air defense but the videos that are
going around online indicate that this
was indeed some sort of interception and
we will get more information about what
exactly was intercepted it comes as
there have been a couple crews or
ballistic missiles fired at the
ukrainian capital tonight we are still
getting more information on those and
the second largest city in ukraine
kharkiv also taking a lot of fire
tonight as reports indicate russian
forces are trying to make more of an
offensive towards the ukrainian capital
again the major concern is that this
city could be choked off amid a larger
push by the russians in this larger
blitz of the city and if that does
indeed happen you will likely see a
number of waves of attacks so that the
russian forces can work their way into
the capital but make no mistake there
are not only uh ukrainian forces but
also civilians who say they will stay
here and they will fight even if this
battle turns into more of an urban
guerrilla warfare style of war
laura
we've been seeing
really heart wrenching video today
from
the underground subways in kiev and
other places other areas that civilians
feel certainly more safe in people
taking obviously their children some
belongings some food
sometimes their pets uh and it's it's
difficult to watch um but this is what
war ends up looking like especially in
the early stages where civilians just
try to find cover wherever they can and
a lot of the women that were interviewed
basically said we don't know where to go
we're go we're going to the only place
we know is safe
and others are already fleeing across
the border into poland
where they're
being allowed to go
tonight so that's what we're seeing as
far as the civilians on the ground in
the vulnerable areas
it's heartbreaking to see these images
and scenes playing out in the ukrainian
capital i think many people are having
trouble wrapping their mind around
what's actually taking place these are
scenes you would expect to see out of a
world war ii documentary people
underground in the subway system trying
to get away from air raids over the past
24 hours in this city a european capital
air raid sirens blaring as people run
for cover
and
an air campaign against a european city
is just something that is such a major
escalation and something that really
even
those ukrainians who believed something
would happen and there would be some
level of invasion no one envisioned that
it would be like this it was the worst
case nightmare scenario and as we've
seen civilians really just doing
anything they can to get out of the way
going underground if they can and those
who have the resources and ability
trying to make it to the polish border
laura trey very qui very quickly um i've
been through kiev and other parts of
ukraine uh fairly extensively and the
historic landmarks not that that's the
most important thing right now but the
historic churches that
that really speak to the heart of what
kiev is um there was some talk on
another network tonight that those could
be targeted do you have any sense that
that is actually the case tonight
we don't have any information about
churches or any sort of religious
facilities in this city being targeted
one thing to keep in mind though is that
this has been really a source of
strength for people having the churches
here when we arrived in kiev a few weeks
ago we went into one of these beautiful
churches and spoke with an older woman
who was praying and she was praying for
peace and it was just a place for her to
feel comfortable and hopeful and still
even at this hour we expect if there are
troops ever coming into this city and it
is a very real possibility that the
churches could be a place where people
could feel safe and be away from the
streets and any sort of military
operations that might take place
trey thank you so much and stay safe out
there please hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else